let me try the fat ones yeah definitely
get this crispy one right here right
here that's a hot it's really hot
hi I'm Jackson went from China and today
I'm teaming up with first we feast to
celebrate the end of Chinese New Year
and today we're gonna make some
dumplings Wong tongues with Mary Ann and
Hannah from Mimi Chang's
right actually I've never tried making
dumplings I don't know if I believe that
no okay maybe you never tried
seriously seriously never try right
cause there's always like my mom doing
it do you like spice I can't like in
Shanghai needs it's Cod it's a no-go
it means like said no no you know themed
head yes parents are gonna be so proud
there you think oh you understand
Chinese
okay so we'll leave the spice on the
side but we're making celery chicken
wontons
actually I don't know what's the
difference of one ton and Xiao long bao
so I think wontons are square shape in
the wrapper and it's much thinner and
it's more of like a ravioli or a little
bite of morsel and I feel like Xiao long
bao is juicier and it's got the soup
inside and you have to be careful about
how you eat it so you don't burn your
lips off what about dumplings dumplings
are happy medium I think yeah yes
definitely so it has a circular wrapper
and then you're choosing your meat as
well and then the freshest vegetables
are most important - okay cool let's get
started
so first up we're gonna wrap the Mimi
chain dumpling which is our mother
signature dumpling that she's known for
it has organic chicken and zucchini so
everybody grab one skin
okay so moisten the edges all around
with a little bit of water that looks
good so far now we're going to take one
scoop of filling and you don't want to
put too much you don't put too much yeah
about a tablespoon it's better less is
more like this oh my gosh you're gonna
go hungry with that yeah okay are you on
a diet no this is is enough look one
more support yeah yeah good so then
we're gonna fold it right in the middle
like a taco and pinch it yeah pitch in
the middle yeah in the middle like that
and then you start pleating you can fold
it over your finger oh my god
like this all in one side like this yeah
oh that's looking good so it's really
important when you're folding it just
seal it up really well because it keeps
all the juices inside right or else it's
gonna leak yeah exactly
and nobody wants a leaky dumpling
[Music]
okay so we're gonna do the chili oil
wontons now they are our Chinese New
Year tradition every February so start
off the same way by moistening all the
edges around and you're gonna put a
little bit less than the tablespoon yeah
so this I'm just literally folding in
half like a piece of paper then we fold
it like this so add a little bit water -
wow that looks like a 1-ton because it
is right here okay so you're gonna fold
it we're gonna dab this side with water
oh and then we're gonna tape it yeah
tape it done there you go our plates are
basically full I think we should cook
them are you hungry it's over I don't
wait to eat so you need a nonstick
frying pan you got your beautiful
dumplings that you made so once the oil
is heated we're going to add the
dumpling come check it out okay so what
you want to do is I have it sizzle like
this and then we're going to pan sear
till it's golden and then add water
about two to three times with the lid to
steam it through and then they'll crisp
up again right after okay yeah so while
we're doing that why don't we boil some
wontons okay
what I have to do can I can i yes you're
in charge you're a hunter isn't
participating usually in hotpot we just
do this okay let me teach you this in
Shanghai nice one ton is caught
when done when done when then that
basically one for dumplings
it's jealous right yeah but in Cantonese
is Goudy that's okay that's very let's
check on the pan-fried dumplings so
there's almost no water left so we're
gonna add a little bit more water
because they need a steam through a
little bit okay more you can tell
they're done when they start ballooning
out and the wrappers become a bit more
transparent the whole process should
take about six to seven minutes yeah so
yeah to pan fry I can do that or you can
ya bout for that so this takes about
four to five minutes you see how all the
wontons are floating up what I want to
see is the wrappers are cooked through
and
I want the meat to be cooked there as
well so hot yeah looks good it looks ha
I used to grow up it's just like this
this is the most organic yes it's our
mom usually just flips it over into a
plate like this too
and there's different sauces good also
we pulled the wontons out cuz they're
done cooking do you want try one oh can
i yeah they're really hot though how is
that is it burning hot this is when you
circle speechless that it's here I see I
feel home okay
oh really you guys should try one but
yeah you try one okay great are you
feeding me I can't wait to take these to
feed my friend okay great yeah a bunch
of people a lot of people but you know
I'm only a close with one of them
just to let you guys know legendary
China magnet all right let's go meet
your one friend let's go
[Music]
so Marion and Hana I wanna introduce you
to my friend China Mack my friend Sean
pleasure and also my friends grandma
thora Oh
so anyhow they're stumbling in my life
well this really Wow
it's good maxilla out of 10 how much
will you make honestly this is really
good right like like nine and a half
what's that's the only going down fine I
don't this one is really good thank you
that's my meat rather who bought your
case if in the past quickie what laughs
watching a hideous thing that's a loss
as well go straight for your name
she said it's ten out of ten because
it's very everything's on point I'm very
happy today for everyone you know coming
to join in for dinner and just want to
say happy Chinese New Year to everyone
[Music]